un nuage de quatre mètres comme amuse
bouche la création prolifération de
florence arnold était la première
découverte artistique de la nuit blanche
saint-quentinoise une première
participation pour la ville de trappes
quatre lieux se sont associés le temps
de cette soirée
ça nous permet de travailler avec
d'autres yeux de la communauté d'agglo
et d'avoir une vraie synergie ensemble
et ça c'est une vraie volonté qu'on a
entre le programmateur d'essayer d'avoir
des projets communs ils ont plus de
force comme ça pour cette nouvelle
édition les visites ont pu se faire en
circuit prochaine étape ou voisins le
bretonneux et sa biennale de la peinture
du coup ça permet de pas se brider et de
bas justement d'avoir plusieurs
plusieurs lieux à visiter et à découvrir
avec des artistes m'ajouter
majoritairement de région parisienne qui
ont proposé des oeuvres qui ont été
sélectionnés et en l'honneur de la nuit
blanche on à l'association soudja qui
nous a fait une création numérique en
fait comme des tableaux vivants qui sont
au milieu du hall et qui bouge
de temps en temps un circuit qui s'est
poursuivie à la ferme de bel ébat de
guyancourt et la commanderie
le prochain grand rendez vous culturel
de l'agglomération débute le 7 novembre
la semaine des écrivains persécutés